[Music]
does it live in a jungle no
oh
is it really fast
no does it live on the great plains of
africa no
hey
what is going on hold on guys betty be
careful on the road
jerry
get back in your car right now remain
with your feet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're getting out of here
terry what is this
just see worldwide
is anyone doing better than we are
[Music]
how do we know they're coming they're
coming
ready
[Music]
go go
[Music]
[Music]
i need you to help you're asking me to
leave my family
i'm not gonna force you
but don't pretend you're not well suited
for the job
[Music]
baby tell the kids i'm coming back
just know i'm coming back
[Music]
[Music]
you get the truck come back with the
money that's 2.5 million dollars per
head
if you come back alive
[Music]
from tile
[Music]
foreign
it's been 10 years since the zombie
apocalypse
and this dysfunctional family merry
christmas do you know what i would like
i don't give a [ __ ] with you
have survived by using their wits
[Music]
and by following the rules those are for
[ __ ] nothing personal how could that
not be personal that's like my whole
thing yeah you're right it was personal
on october 18 what made you do it and
don't say the script can this be just
between us
drugs costs money
didn't see that coming right
new kind of zombies stronger faster
better adapted to the hunt they are much
more afraid of us than we are of them
you'll be the first to die but i like
your enthusiasm you might die yeah thank
you for your sacrifice
from the director of venom
need arrive oh yeah
and writers of deadpool
casablanca
oh god well i think i would have made a
damn fine president i think those cigars
are left over from the clinton
administration
academy award nominee woody harrelson
let's kick some gifts academy award
nominee jesse eisenberg right now right
now academy award nominee abigail
breslin is that weird
boom academy award winner emma stone
what the [ __ ] zombieland doubletap
time
for shut up that saying is very 2009.
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil
why are you back here clear your
conspiracies weren't true when we were
kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this
i'm afraid claire i'm afraid of what
they're gonna do to this town
see umbrella they have an incident i'm
talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
people are getting sick
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
[Music]
we have to contain
sometimes
[Music]
split up
[Music]
and i take a deep breath and i get real
high tonight
[Music]
we gotta get out of here
[Music]
we're gonna take umbrella down
[Applause]
three months ago i was cutting grass in
my front yard
and the mailman shows up with a letter
from the army
now i'm here
no idea where i'm going to end up
here we go
welcome to france
what happened here
some questions don't have good answers
[Music]
there's a lot of soldiers out there
there's only four of us
find out what's inside that compound
your soldiers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what's not in that wall
[Music]
what do you do with those people
they have been given a purpose
[Music]
[Music]
i'm a long way from home
leave me alone
[Music]
this is way tommy to help me get my
sister back
i've seen the bodies
they're terrorists they're killers ain't
that what you do
we need you
who's your sister
oh
fantastic
you reckon you can get us in there
easy
i'm gonna make this right
so i'm gonna go into that bunker
and we're gonna kill every last one of
those sons of [ __ ] [ __ ] i
oh what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
oh yes
it's one hell of a lovely skull good
work rhys you dumb son of a [ __ ]
come on
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] me
[Music]
i'm not i'm not infected i'm not
infected please
nothing happened the way it was supposed
to happen
six billion people on earth when the
infection hit
i'm a survivor living in new york city
i will be at the south street seaport
every day at midday when the sun is
highest in the sky
[Music]
i'll just sleep
[Music]
eat your vegetables don't just push them
around eat them i'm not playing
[Music]
[Music]
one hank midway through the g's
[Music]
god didn't do this
we did
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
hello melanie
morning class
[Music]
once upon a time
there was a woman
the most beautiful and amazing woman in
all the world
no you just touched up watch
no please don't do that they're only
children
[Music]
one day
she was attacked by a monster
but then the girl came running up
and killed it
and the woman said
you are my special girl
and i'll never
let you go
[Music]
she saved me and you're still afraid of
it
yeah
and you should be too
i am producing a vaccine
and she is the main ingredient
what am i
hope
that's what you are
i just want to live
everyone wants that she loves you
the hell is this
the world is falling apart
you can save people melanie
you can save
everybody my god
[Music]
what did you do
[Music]
welcome to london
we're heading into this restaurant
although safe outside the security zone
planting remains a wasteland
our large number of bodies still have to
be cleared from the original outbreak of
infection
[Applause]
[Music]
i think that makes you the youngest
person in the entire country
welcome back and we wish you luck in
your new eyes oh i missed you so much
this is what it's all about gentlemen
family's starting again did you like it
it's amazing
[Music]
are you going to tell us what happened
to mum
the last infected human died six months
ago
we weren't here six months ago
have you come into direct contact with
the infected
execute code red
it's probably nothing
[Music]
we've lost control killed everyone
shadow that's it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i thought
prepare
for the final chapter
of the epic horror franchise
wreck for apocalypse
in this peaceful town
on these quiet streets
something terrifying
something horrifying
is coming
excuse me we're close
what the hell was it a wild animal this
is really awful maybe the worst thing
i've ever seen what was it wild animals
so what are you thinking
i'm thinking zombies
what
you know the undead
ghouls
[Music]
you look
gorgeous
oh my
are you in this together
flesh eating zombies don't joke it's
really really creepy
[Music]
oh man this isn't going to end well
they gravitate towards things they did
when they were alive
did she just say chardonnay yeah she did
[Music]
welcome to my world zombies
i've been telling you this is all gonna
end badly
well that's unfortunate i'm quite
confident of my ability to defend myself
against the undead
i can see that
excuse me
those are some pretty good cuts you
played some minor league ball didn't you
well a little class a it was a long time
ago
[Music]
what am i doing with my life i just want
to connect
why can't i connect with people
all right it's cause i'm dead
i wish i could introduce myself but i
don't remember my name i think it
started with an r that's all i have left
it's kind of a bummer
i shouldn't be so hard on myself i mean
we're all dead
this is my best friend we even have
almost conversations sometimes
[Music]
they call these guys ponies
they'll eat anything with a heartbeat i
mean i will too but
at least i'm conflicted about it
[Music]
nice watch
[Music]
[Music]
be
dead
it's too much
don't be creepy don't be creepy where
are you
this is the corpse infected with the
plague it is uncaring
unfeeling
incapable of remorse i don't understand
but he's changing and he feels and he's
learning to be human again oh my god is
that him
yeah
except
you started something here whatever it
is that you two have
it's infecting the others dad they're
somehow curing themselves they are not
curing themselves
come with
we're seeing corpses fighting skeleton
sir how do we shoot shoot this
hi huh
[Music]
how'd you die
how old are you because you could be
20-something but you could also be a
teenager you know you have one of those
faces
[Music]
[Music]
you